Taylor Twellman here on the show how are
you Taylor Goodrich hello everybody I'm
doing great I'm doing great we're just
talking about how I am just so locked
into this world cup and trying to put my
finger on as to why and I I just
understand the bigness of it and what it
means to so many people and nations and
even when you see the video of Panama
getting its figurative brains beaten in
and they finally score a goal and it
you've seen the viral video Taylor going
all over the place yeah rich it's so
hard for the American sports fan to
fully understand I think what goes into
everything because you know yearly you
were talking about the NFL playoffs the
NBA playoffs and in the match March
Madness and the majors in golf
this comes every four years and every
single country starts that process the
moment rushes over rich 2022 starts for
so many countries so Panama gets their
brains beat in and yet they score their
first World Cup goal ever in their
nation and that's why you see that
celebration it's kind of it's really
hard to make a comparison because I just
don't think there is well in terms of
getting started for the next World Cup I
also mentioned it was difficult to watch
Panama get adapted like that especially
since that could have easily been the
United States spot it's the United
States that comparatively worse to
Panama but that they couldn't make it
and we watched what Panama is doing with
its opportunity no rich your your
feeling in your gut watching that was
the exact same feeling for me and I
think for so many of us I mean I remind
everyone the United States absolutely
destroyed Panama right before the
debacle in Trinidad 4-0 they went to
Panama got a result so it wasn't direct
pana ball versus the United States but
the reality is is that the United States
could not get a result against a second
team at Trinidad and that ultimately
turns into the reason why you and I are
watching 6:1 England over Panama want to
throw up because the reality is pan a
ball qualified in the United States
didn't hmm so let's
discuss then I imagine what the United
States needs to do to get back on this
stage Taylor let's let's get into that
since obviously that is kind of front
and center with Panama's result against
England rich it's an interesting
question and quite honestly it's a three
to four hour discussion type of thing
because it's not a black-and-white
answer but what I mean by that is that
so many things in our country with the
sport of soccer and I'm not this isn't
about basketball baseball football and
hockey even to a certain extent but
soccer is played developed and quite
honestly commercialized completely
different around the world and I use
this analogy the United States is trying
to play checkers while the rest of the
world's playing chess whether it's
promotion/relegation whether it's pay to
play whether it's coaching education you
can have a legit and I'm not saying we
have to do it the way the rest of the
world does it either and I'm also not
saying if you have an accent you know
more than the American but rich if this
isn't a wake-up call for the rest of the
country and quite honestly any of the
power brokers that are in this country
with the sport of soccer then that I'm
gonna say you're insane because the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over expecting a
different result
now I hope this is a wake-up call for
all of those money-making power broking
people but rich let me kind of go a
little deeper into what I mean by an
example of coaching development Iceland
is the size of Corpus Christi Texas and
it's about three hundred thirty thousand
plus population if I was if Rich Eisen
wants to become the highest developed an
educated coach in that country it is
roughly going to cost you $2,000 in the
United States of America Rich Eisen who
has no history with soccer wants to
become in a level Pro coach with the
amount of travel and the amount of
everything you put in Richards oh it's
over five figures way more eight you're
looking at 25 to 40 grand depending on
where you're on the country so so my
argument right there is if you want to
make it if you want to put a dent into
the deficiency of what we're doing in
our country any single human being that
is coaching the sport of soccer in our
country you
to be educated and licensed by proper
professionals and make it accessible
make it affordable
whether you're coaching at a parish
whether you're coaching at a local team
whether you're coaching at a travel team
I don't care what it is but if I Celyn
can figure it out on such a micro level
the United States can it's just whether
or not they're willing to fully roll up
their sleeves and get into that kind of
conversation and I'm not totally sure
that is there yet now obviously the
United States has a new president so
we're going to wait and see but I think
which the better answer to your question
is call me in 10 years and we'll see if
it really was a i opening moment for the
united states well in terms of Taylor
Twellman of ESPN joining me here on the
Richardson show so but in terms of the
ice the comparison that you've just made
a young man or woman in Iceland can grow
up and just look obviously at what team
iceland has been able to do so far and
say i want to be part of that a young
man or woman in this country can see the
NCAA tournament football and basket I
mean there's so many other ways for
somebody to imagine their dream and also
exact their riches and so I guess my
follow-up question this is why have the
women's side seemed to have gotten this
straight
and the men can't a great question rich
in it's one that many people asked in in
in the sports world because it's a
honest-to-god simple question the rest
of the world has not developed women the
way them the women have in this country
however you ask me in 5-10 years from
now the French the European women player
that's completely different there's a
right now the Colombian the South
American women national team player and
the European national team player in
women's soccer is exponentially growing
because they finally are putting
resources into that and then that begs
the question is the United States women
national team still so reliant on the
athleticism and not the technique in the
for lack of a better word that
the technical part of it and the
tactical part of it I think the United
States women are going to be really
challenged if not next year a world cup
for year you know five years from today
and the reason why is because the United
States women with title nine of whatnot
they've been afforded the opportunity to
play the sports for much sooner than the
rest of the world has that's quite
simply what it is but when you now talk
to and I was in Paris doing the US
France friendly a couple weeks ago
before the World Cup started and the
French women are all over the billboards
now and now all of a sudden it those
schools are being opened for the French
women I'm telling you watch out and that
goes back to my initial point about that
male or female coaching the game I'm not
sure our coaches and our developing
players at the same rate the rest of the
world as enrich another food for thought
when you turn 16 17 around the world
you're a professional when you turn 16
17 in our country you're going to
college and in soccer you're playing two
and a half three months that's it so a
scout told me on the male side five
years from now expect to see 50 to 60
Christian polysix in Europe because the
14 to 15 year old good soccer player
they're all over this country it's the
problem is 16 to 19 or I would say 16 to
21 the rest of the world grows and we
stop or stagnate because we think we've
got a college scholarship now it's over
where the rest of the world is actually
training with professionals and still
getting their education people think
when I bring that up they're like no no
no it means we don't want education
that's not true if you read that's
reboot about the German national team
rich and TAS one a on developing players
was educated it makes perfect sense why
would you want stupid players mm-hmm so
they wanted their players to be educated
and training at a higher level we've got
to figure out that age 16 to 21
otherwise you and I are going to have
this conversation I think every 12 to 16
years by the way I love that name das
reboot great at my team in the morning
when I'm
last one for you Taylor in about a
minute's time if he can this looks like
it's a wide open tournament right now
who do you like who are you seeing that
might even be just a cut above the rest
here it's a good question rich I mean
the World Cups been very you know we've
had some some surprises I do think from
the beginning I have felt it's got Spain
Brazil final all written all over it
I don't like to be someone that
backtracks I'm gonna stay with Spain I I
look at this team and even though they
tied 3-3 against weird although in
Portugal two of those three goals were
self-inflicted and stupid and this is a
team that can pass the ball the deaths
they can play it to death they can get
shutouts how many teams in this World
Cup can get shutouts
very few Spain's one of them I still
think Spain is there now two teams that
could be thrown them the French are more
talented than any team at the World Cup
however we all know they got to be in
the right mood at the right time can
they do that for six straight games and
I still think if Neymar gets out of his
own way and just plays the game Brazil's
got the most complete roster Taylor
great chat let's chat soon thanks again
buddy
you bet that's uh ESPN's Taylor Twellman
here on the Rich Eisen show you can
follow them at Taylor 12-minute the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience